In this lesson,
we're going to discuss the details of
how to build native Android wear apps.
These can do so
much more than just notifications, and
you have a full Android
implementation to help you out here.
Having Android underneath means that
most of your Android concepts that
you're familiar with apply here too.
So you'll be reusing a lot
of your existing knowledge.
So to build an Android Wear app,
we're going to discuss how these apps
are built, how wearables communicate
with the outside world, how to
create user interfaces for them, and
how to implement useful functionality
with them, such as sensor processing.